après tout ce qu'elle a traversé elle
essaie de réparer ce qui lui est arrivé
le cerveau il a lancé contre nous
personne n'en veut à Jil pour ça
personne ouais
docteur Taylor
j'ai analysé l'ADN d'une morsure qu'on a
trouvé sur la carcasse du Nork le
prélèvement contient une souche de virus
t sans déconner j'ai trouvé un lien
entre les personnes qui ont été
contaminées elles ont toutes visité
Alcatraz récemment
docteur Taylor on va pouvoir donner le
coup de départ de
notre propre création
il se transforme vite sans même être
mordus
salut je suis Rebecca que voulez-vous
que je leur dise quelqu'un
vous pensez que ça a quelque chose à
voir avec notre opération du moment
sur une île hantée par le désespoir je
vais me servir de mon virus pour faire
table rase une nouvelle menace
[Musique]
ça augure rien de bon
doit être arrêté
[Musique]
à toi
on en est à la dernière étape il n'y a
pas de justice
ouais mais là c'est terminé
et maintenant je vais t'allumer on s'en
occupe tous ensemble
après ça je le prends au moins 18 mois
de vacances